what up welcome back to another episode
of the h3 podcast live at twitch TV for
slash h3h3 productions today we have an
absolute slammer
on deck this is my phone already
Jonathan you're busted about it okay
today we have Jake Paul in the building
see any pretty legendary at this point
so original guy that invented the ER
movements you know Sheila kleiner would
not have exist no I know and I'm
thankful for that every day
nobody I mean you guys you everybody
knows who Jake Paul's at this point I
mean the guy see what you will about him
but he's achieved a lot I mean he just
hosted the Teen Choice Awards last week
I caught a clip of it I did a pretty
good job honestly it really did actually
I mean he was natural he's comfortable
and with him is coming Chris wolf the
KTLA reporter who broke the initial
story so we're going to start with Jake
he's going to come in we're going to
talk a little bit and then later in the
hour we are going to bring over Chris
wolf to sit in with us it's going to be
a flipping rump and I'm so happy to be
here and I'm so happy to have you guys
what this is really excited about this
episode so before we bring him in you
thank the sponsors yes
thank you to me on DS and naturebox for
sponsoring this episode appreciate you
so much what was it for them this show
won't be possible and a shout out to all
of our twitch prime subscribers god
bless you if you have Amazon Prime you
can attach it to twitch and subscribe
for free so thank you to you guys now
talking about Jake how are you feeling
about this doing this interview
I'm really excited next to me I have to
say this is one of the most exciting
episode probably there's freakin live
had yeah I agree
let me turn this freaking vibration off
yeah I feel it I'm just I'm I'm happy
that he like came that he's willing to
come into the Lions Den yeah it's
awesome so I I have to respect the guy
for that I mean he could have easily
just said no not sure and I was and I
was straightforward I said KTLA guys
coming too and he was
cool that's fun so I got a tip the
beanie and the Fedora to him right off
the bat for agreeing to participate in
this I know I said in our last video
that I don't want to make it anymore
Jake Paul videos so we thought what
better way to follow that up with then
inviting Jake Paul on our podcast that's
not actually true we've been talking to
Jake for lekha actually seems like a
month already for yeah bringing him on
man but it just seemed right now for
some reason it took some time to get ma
he's busy guys so at any rate a guy
needs no introduction
mm-hmm I think we're ready to bring him
in yeah so without further ado let's
bring in the the [ __ ] mr. Jake Paul
what up dog
all right yeah we're live ready to go
what up did you watch
yeah you're good what's up doc what was
you guys doing good man excited happy
you're here
most of the like hey hey stuff on me is
like not funny but you guys kill it like
I love hello thank you really good well
I appreciate you saying that I am
sometimes when we make fun of people
like I like to do it in a way where it's
not it should be like digging at the
core of who this person is I don't know
is that everyone oh yeah on board that
just happens I like that guy again
yeah chill out dude yeah calm down going
down all right we get every discipline
okay all right no yeah it's funny it's
because everyone makes mistakes you
gotta everyone's got to be made fun of
you know see that's and you do feel like
the criticism that's come against you
has been deserved like how do you feel
because everybody on YouTube it's like
you feel like everyone's ganging up on
you I feel like it's 50/50 I feel like
it's like the half of youtubers like you
know were Jay Paul are and like we're
gonna support and blah blah blah
and then the other half of the YouTube
which is I think like kids that are
filled with like a lot of like hate and
they just love like the drama and stuff
they always they always come for me and
yeah I think some of its valid I think
some of it is like okay yeah that like
deserves to be hated on like really do
did you just do that because I mean like
I said I'm nice up a lot and I do dumb
things
and I'm just like I'm I'm just I don't
know I'm just weird and like posting
videos every day like there's a there's
so much you know creativity that goes
into it and like sometimes you know it
comes off the wrong way and like you
make mistakes to slip up and it's part
of life so is there some things that you
can recall where you're like this I did
I kind of deserve to get [ __ ] for and
other stuff you're like this one
I think people took too far I think um
the it's every day bro thing yeah like I
think people took that too far it's like
it was just such a juicy me well
whatever the the England is my city like
all that's funny yeah but like there was
people who were legitimate like this kid
needs to die because he made a rap song
I do ridiculous like I live like I'm not
a rapper bro like right like Anna and I
saw the I saw even when post was in here
yeah I was like I was I was watching
that segment of your podcast and he's
like to look really like he's like he's
like checking my flows and like my
lyrics and like picking apart the whole
entire thing and it's like yo it's like
he made his first vlog like he's a big
rapper I'm a big blogger if he made his
first vlog like I could easily go in and
be like oh this business is this you
know well I don't recall what post said
but I don't really either it was a
negative overall you you felt are you
fan of post do I love his long real I
told Matt relations that's how I am
so it what kind of it felt especially
bad hearing him [ __ ] on your oh no I
don't care about I don't care about who
it is right you know like that's that's
the name of the game but and I still
thought it was like I'm funny you know
I'm taking all this stuff like
light-hearted I guess you guys kind of
present it like real music though
because you get you take it you shoot it
like a real doe video you have producers
like a real music video you do shows
like a real music video we always are
going I hear of it I hear a tech yeah it
is then um we can kind of hear ourselves
yeah their echo is it gone
dan are you live it was meditated my
auto tune from the
no yeah it was so okay sorry sorry go
ahead sorry no like I totally get we
presented as real music but like we made
that song in three hours we made the
music video in three hours really yeah I
was wondering about that because I mean
the product it was really well shot it
was really well edited thank you
you got you must have a team working on
that [ __ ] right like 12 hours when I
need support like if I'm doing like two
videos a day or whatever it is yeah like
I have like editors that help and stuff
but the this a new edit your own videos
most of the time really yeah most of the
time and and and if I can't that's what
I like I offered it to someone like for
example I'm going to Pennsylvania
tonight so I'll be on a flight a red-eye
and so I can't I can't I won't be able
to get it done is there a difference you
feel like when someone added to a verse
when you edit it no it's all good and
low people can't tell the difference so
why do I waste your time editing it um I
think I always try to like innovate the
game and like push it forward and
forward and forward and like with the
edits and like I'm always thinking about
how I can add in like more memes sound
effect right crazy stuff so on and so
forth
and I try to have the other people edit
it as much as possible yeah I will do I
mean we try getting editors so many
times and for us it never works like
they don't they can never get it there
it's so personal I found I found the
legend
you got a lightning head attack [ __ ]
yeah get out of this jack he loves you
jack
so without him I'd be dead but like I'm
sorry I got too far away um yeah god
bless your mic etiquette we have so much
guests in here or like they might end
their like this this is thanks for one
second is like oh [ __ ]
drop out here I'm a rapper right I'm
rats everyday Road so getting back to
what we talked about oh one more thing
sorry to interrupt the I was pissed at
the producer who made it every day bro
why because we're doing ad-libs right
and I was like I'm not a rapper at the
beginning took the ad lid off daunting
done that ended me in like a
a second viewing on the edit before went
out dude that's how fast it was right
twelve twelve hours from making song to
like music like 18 hours from making the
song to being online that is you can say
what you will about you a lot of people
love you love you behave you but the
Hustle is insane thank you room I mean
anyone who denies that it's just not
being honest I appreciate that
yeah that's for sure that that's what
it's all about and like hard work and
and you can get anywhere in life I think
so what is your schedule line yeah it
must be insane yeah like I basically I
basically like never sleep always doing
something because I'm I'm like running a
business doing the YouTube thing acting
thing like writing movies working on
like a couple different TV shows
obviously like the merch stuff
excuse me like I make investments so in
ever ends I mean probably same for you
guys yeah I mean it's it's hard to keep
up these days for sure let me go back to
what we were talking about in the
beginning because you were saying some
things you deserve to get criticized for
some things not and the one thing that
you think you didn't get deserved for
was it's every day bro yeah well so I I
agree it was fun making fun I think the
thing that is that it went so big that
it became like such a it was just so
good to talk about right yeah that was
shocking did that surprise you do I
didn't think it was gonna get that big I
like literally abusive Evan like ninety
nine ninety but the thing is like
anywhere I go like anyone who's a
phantom I could sing the whole song
starts finished yeah I think for like
under like eight even we can guide of
but under 18 they're like I'm all for
this you know right um I didn't think I
didn't know I was gonna get that to me
like I woke up I was like I'm vlogging
what do I do today I want to make a song
in one day that's how it started and so
like I had no idea that it was going to
blow up like that interesting so I agree
people like you wishing death on you
we're making a video they don't like is
ridiculous but so what are some things
you've done that you think are worth the
criticism you've got
trying to go through the list man I
forget I don't even like I try to forget
all the things I get I get criticized
for oh um I think we'll I think there's
a lot of things that you criticize for
that's okay we can work what's an
example like I guess we can go as well
until the hair let me pull up I've got
[ __ ] 50 things all ya see - nice
I guess what we can come back to that
later but anyway I
I think it's a I was saying before you
came in but big props to you for coming
in here and sitting down with us I think
that's very cool that you came today I
appreciate that a lot
thank you minute yeah and I I think I
love your guys's content I know it's
like bashing me sometimes but it's funny
and I think a lot of people have like
the wrong perception of Who I am
you know that everyone thinks I'm like
this crazy young kid running around like
breaking stuff and I don't think about
like what I do and I'm just like going
nuts so what is the difference between
Jake Paul on camera and off camera
hmm I say I think it's like Jake Paul on
cameras like okay like we're doing this
for entertainment like a ton of people
are gonna be watching this it's telling
a story it's like a heightened version
of Who I am and it's super fast pace and
and I'm like always got the jokes on
always got the you know the the pranks
rolling that that's how I describe it
and then off camera it's like on that on
that same person but it's like I'm more
chill yeah I kind of just let them hang
out you know I'm doing my thing and like
me and my friends joke around but it's
not like loud and in-your-face yeah I
mean people call me a douche bag a lot
but like because of the how they see me
on camera I think like even
like news reported saying like people
who knew me clearly everyone was sexy
anything like bro that's the funniest
thing I've ever seen because they know
me and I'm just like I'm just like I do
that stuff like as I explore the moment
sometimes I get in the moment so what's
you when you during that news report was
that like on camera Jake or off-camera
Jake
do you know what I mean dude that was
like way too on Kim okay okay yeah I was
like I'm still gonna send like it wasn't
even me I was like playing a character
that my neighbors hate me about I'm
still gonna send it with like the silly
voice run and like jumpy on the news van
like I would never do if I saw a news
reporter like off-camera Jake I'd just
be like yo like what's up bro like yeah
oh you want to remit dope like let's
talk about some cracker um but I never
like and I think even some like that
it's not like on camera off camera Jake
some of its like sometimes I I do get in
those modes of just like madness and and
like I just want to have fun and like
make people laugh and be funny and
entertaining and and I like watching
myself like on videos and sometimes I
you watch back your videos yeah really
yeah so you'll post a video and then
you'll watch the whole thing you watch
it more than once um not more than once
no just like one time like fresh like
sometimes it's down like we sit down
like with the squad and like watch the
videos and so sometimes I'm watching
myself and I'm like bro you're being
boring right now like this vlog sucks
and I'm like okay I remember that like I
can get better at like you're studying
exact time studying myself and improving
so I think it's like I'm always trying
to get better at being on camera like
doing the next funnier thing someone
said to me to actually they were like ah
I forget what we did I think we like
blew someone's car up in a video and
like one of my friend's dad's was like
call them and it's like you guys are
crazy like when does and what's next
like what are you going to do next like
when you're going to run out of videos
and that's like it's ah I always said
like the Simpsons went on for 30 seasons
like I'm never going to run out of ideas
but it's like yeah what is next like how
do we beat that like I always want to
beat myself and I
things like becoming better every day
bro so I want to get better on camera
every day right you know to define a
correlation between like you say when
you watch back your videos you're like
man I was boring in that one do you find
a correlation between the success of a
video or do you think that it doesn't
really matter like you watch the back of
video and see if that one wasn't very
good but maybe it gets a lot of views
yeah final phrase even know I'm super
critical sometimes I'll be like this
vlog sucks and it'll get like way more
views and another one where I'm like is
amazing actually like two of my favorite
videos or like they sent a lot of views
but they're not like my most viewed
video right um that happens to us yeah
yeah every time because like you never
know what the audience is going to eat
up yeah it so every every day it's
different it's like what can I do here
like do I talk about this or you know do
I do this prank how do i you know well
before we get any deeper actually do you
want to talk about something that just
came up this morning you probably know
what it is yeah I mean I'm not really
familiar with the faze clan I don't know
them I really don't know what they are
but just this morning this morning right
oh yes our usual day that's when it all
I kind of got when did you post your new
video posted it today okay so gay posted
a new video today where he basically
accused the owner of phase right phase
banks I don't know they all have on
their BIOS are all owners yeah okay so
he's a phase guy he's one of the face
owners to collective and basically
saying that this guy choked out your
assistant and her I saw her neck it's a
completely black and blue bruised over
and it's been like he's on Twitter
saying that he said you can't get much
lower than this as a human I have no
words this is way beyond internet beef
at this point I promise you guys I'm
pursuing legal action to the highest
degree in addition to my response video
where your thoughts on that
my thoughts are like I would never lie
to my fans this happened how would you
know I mean how how would you have that
level of certainty where you're like I'm
gonna put this in a video and [ __ ]
exactly was this guy so like there is
multiple people there who saw it happen
right um obviously she has a bruise on
her neck her D like you don't just get a
bruise from like like getting hit like
yeah be like yeah like and and not only
that phase was there he admitted to it
on DMS yeah I saw that he was like I was
definitely there bro yeah I think that
he said he was drunk
he said he got into a fight that night
and he said he lost his phone so clearly
he was being belligerent he said he
doesn't remember anything the only thing
I really want to say further more to the
point like it happened the police are
involved
my sister has made a police report
Warwick the club that they're at has
cameras and because there's there you go
for the to exact amount the truth will
come out that's and that's all I say
I trust that the police are going to
handle it Fay's whoever the other people
there can say whatever they want to see
even be Fame or it's not just like
straight up criminal and inanimate and
that's why I want to make a video about
it because I wasn't trying to make it
like this whole drama thing to be honest
I hate drama
like I don't want to be beefing with
anybody but the reason why I made a
video about it is to raise awareness in
general for humans getting assaulted
like it is not okay at all and we
stopped and if it wasn't my assistant he
could have kept on doing that and doing
all the craziest thing about the story
to me is that he didn't know who she was
at the club he just randomly like what
am i right what what rather joking her
out yeah like what the [ __ ] you just
walk to by him or something I'm not and
he did that yeah that's the story just
started choking out a random girl and it
he wasn't trying to choke her or like it
was like he was trying to kiss her Oh
vagina kisser oh it was like a come here
let me kiss you around your neck so I
get my girls baby that's how I got here
I gave her a nice little choke hold your
kiss and the rest is history
ya know but like seriously it's like
it's a problem and that's why I wanted
to make a video about it but the police
are going to handle it like okay there
and the rest of its childish like the
rest of the back-and-forth is childish
like I didn't make that video to accuse
anyone just do anything but like the
rest like their response is whatever it
is it doesn't matter because it half
right bottom line in cash cameras well
I'd be interesting to follow the
development I was really surprised when
I saw that I'm like good family good
joke I got bruised it's pretty serious
yeah that doesn't just happen easily
well I'm looking forward to his response
video too but basically I was like well
how did maybe it wasn't it got him and
then I saw nip Crumpton god bless his
soul England England Italy yeah love
that [ __ ] he that he would hurt and
he posted dance they had from yesterday
when he was admitting to being there as
you said so anyway we'll follow that as
it develops regardless you are a white
boy from Ohio that's right
that's 100% effect what's with that
what's with the white boy thing I don't
even know it's like you're in the studio
and like the ad-libs are coming yeah and
you're like what yeah Cleveland right
okay okay when I was trying to rap dude
like that's right okay so that's just
refreshing to yes they see that you know
and I am from what do you think the
songs good like do you think the video
I'm just I don't mean that in that in a
dickish way yeah I think like I do think
it's good okay yeah I do catchy that's I
mean it's catchy but I mean you know you
made it in three days three hours
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah every hour
excuse me
do people did you guys alright your
lyrics for that no dude and that's why I
feel so bad because I wrote next part oh
you wrote yeah you wrote England is my
city
yeah I'm alright badly [ __ ] yes he
did because I first of all okay I admit
so whoa it's so yeah it's kind of a [ __ ]
up I admit yeah he also [ __ ] read it
presume presumably before he but here a
fella nervous he was like dude I don't
want to rap like he's a CEO of team 10
like he does all the business of Greece
they're all my videos and he's got
sucked into being like one of the
biggest memes of 117 biggest me bro bike
I he was like I don't want to rap I
don't want to rap and I was like dude
you got this it's gonna blow up bro like
people want to see Nick Crompton
yeah Jake Pollard's want to see this
right I don't even know how to read
buzzing I got you i'ma write this I love
that and to be fair dude like dude
England is a city in like Arkansas yeah
but that's not your nice that's not what
you met but it's not president he's not
a pet yeah you know it was a quick
shield I just get it any word yeah but I
mean
and then also in your defense that meme
is fun I mean that's one of the reasons
why that song was so prolific you're
selling merch with England is my city
you're making money and Rancho Mirage
Church baby what is that well well yeah
Jimmy what's stupid what simple
dignified let me explain why down yeah I
just dropped some new merch and it's
selling like a god comma church that
doesn't make sense what is the church
God God use out like no God in church
yes I'm going three hours it does not
excuse them selling merch like we were
actually trying to figure it out because
I really maybe we're member eundel March
and it's selling like a god Church but
I'm not that good I had all like a God
going to church so that's missing like
yeah it's a great line though yeah and
yeah just me made some merch about it I
know I love that it's a thing now you
got it you got it you got to take the
hate and just spiral it back we'll
started calling me Jake the snake March
bro I am Jake the thing what's up why do
people call you Jake the same I don't
know there's just a thing my ex started
calling me that
Oh people just ran with it you know
Iran's rhymes it does it does I tried to
get rival rhymes got merged search I
actually I'm not I'm not that deep into
like the because basically King 10 house
seems like a almost like a puck in what
was supposed to that reality show the
big brother
no no no the old one on MTV Hills bill
real rules everybody
yeah real world it's like a it's just
like an ongoing real world house up I
mean is that a apt comparison yeah it's
pretty great there's always you guys all
just you know bodily fluids you're old
it's a it's like a black eye
it's like a Frau y'all swapping yeah so
yeah essentially yeah that is but you
guys are all under the age of 21 or
however you know I'm 20 okay I don't
even know yeah it varies it's like from
18 to like 24 so okay yeah I'm here you
you started on behind mm-hmm you and
your brother both were well you're Logan
was on vine first right how did no no so
I I actually downloaded vine the first
day I came out and like was making
videos on it I told my brother I was
like yo you're going to like this
he downloaded vine and like starts
making vines comes into the room one day
and is like bro that camera angle sucks
I was like what do you mean and more
followers than you stop I had like 60
followers like mother's favorite right I
had like ten and but he was the older
brother and I set it in front of his
girlfriend at the time he was like got
furious like we are we are competitive
he got angry he got angry and so is the
other anger
no no just like competitive yeah it with
you he has a short-tempered were so
competitive with each other I was I was
wondering about that so youyou found
vine first did you guys always want to
be like entertainers we did it was
abundant it was an accident but we did
it for fun we did it since real like 10
we were making videos so you found vine
first and then Logan came in after you
he [ __ ] bit your style he ripped off
your whole game no no no sorry we got
into a competition
I'm like who could get more followers
okay and then he had he actually had
more followers on bond right ah yes yes
for like the whole entire time in vine
damn boy
but like what's crazy about it is that
like one of the videos that he made went
viral and he grew 5,000 followers and I
grew like 3000 and it's always been that
exact ratio it's then eventually the six
like sixty to a hundred ratio like if he
has five million I always had three
million do so you think that he doesn't
deserve the number one spot in terms of
the
brothers dude I am so proud of him like
he's amazing at creating content and
like he's so creative and always like
pushing the pushing the ball forward I
think he owned the like divine platform
and I wasn't as developed as a content
creator then I was only 16 and he was 18
by the time I was 18 my videos are
better than when he was 18
yeah and like by the time so it's just a
age thing if you were his age if you
guys started you're both 18 years old so
you were twins
well you would have beat them 100% I'm
better-looking okay that's half of
social Nets always right if that's why
I'm not at ten million years away what
it is today because you're both on
YouTube now and your boat and what so I
have wait I might hit 10 million like
right now I'll check the live student
Jake Paul live subscriber count yeah
that's actually special to share that
moment what I hope you do let's see
you're at know my god you're 5,000 wait
yeah a little on the background so here
Jake so you can watch it lower exact you
so much I I need a film that when it
happens okay yeah it's right there for
you so what is Logan it Logan's at like
ten points three wait he panel I thought
you were the king on YouTube so um I
think like the hate and stuff like
hindered it a little bit and he took a
lead and he was like hating on me too so
everyone is like yeah I know that I'm
coming on his side um hello gang yo
fella game it's all he passed I thought
game for him so it's like he doesn't
take it seriously they hate you get you
think he capitalized it on a little bit
instead of being like instead of being
like sympathetic and be like bro I got
you you're like man you [ __ ] maybe
you took a little too much advantage of
this hundred percent yeah which is fine
dude lotta game that's the entertainment
industry right
that is your brother and yeah but he's
like 300 he's like 300,000 subscribers
ahead but like there was a malt when I
first started vlogging he was he was
passing he has 40 days on me he has 40
days of videos on me and I'll be like
one of the fastest I think you'd be
fastest channel out of like a specific
youtuber to hit 10 million subscribers
I'm going to close this because I'm
going
um but but I'll pull it back we're just
going to sit silent what'd your [ __ ]
going to be there in like five minutes
yeah but like the thing is is we always
really constantly pass in each other
like I remember at one point I passed
him again like around five million and I
was like four hundred head and then he
came back for a second and then I like a
little out of the water and so it's like
this constant back and forth but I'm
gonna pass him like and I still get more
views than them every day so it's kind
of weird like he has more subscribers
but I get more views so it's that
happens I just think you're making I
think that me just means you're making
better content than him yeah I don't
know maybe I mean definitely that's what
you were saying between the lines right
all I know we were actually we're
actually eating with each other on
Twitter about it this morning
uh and we were like going back and forth
and like my my ultimatum like it's funny
and it's like a brotherly competition
it's all just for fun but like my
ultimate thing is like I could just ask
him how many subscribers he had when he
was 20 and happier when you always think
that I was I was rolling was there it
was there ever a moment when like all
you're getting all this [ __ ] and you're
like you're like man I wish like did he
ever call you and be like bro like when
you were on the KTLA report and he's
like man what's up dude like chill out
tone it down yeah tone it down right I
know I know Chris is coming yeah you're
done they Logan did the same exact thing
really he was there he was here that
area and he that he did the same as I
think he was messing around with the
camera grabbing it like going up and do
it me like what's up what's up like
messing around cut him out framed me
we're aimed we what do you think framed
me why did they do that
oh let's we can ask him is anything
about the neighbors and they were right
so it would have made sense but bro he
was involved in it he got lucky bro well
so if you could go back in time and be
like I would rather this happen to logan
than me would you do it over because you
got a lot of attention from that I would
not do it over you and II wouldn't want
to have to here's why what you would
take it if I would take it again okay
here's why it got me to a point so my
goal like since I've
here when I was 17 was to be both
traditionally media famous and social
media famous right because my goal is to
be like a huge movie star and being
doing like big movies Logan is this the
same goal right uh yes and most I always
hear him saying stuff like I want to be
the number one entertainer in the world
yeah I think that's his goal okay um and
so I know I knew at some point I needed
to make a jump from social to
traditional right which is why I got
onto the Disney show they were like yo
you're not going to get paid a lot for
this like you're going to have to be
there five days a week for like
potentially four years etc and I knew
that was going to help me boost myself
into traditional media so adults like I
get into an uber and the uber drivers
like yo like what do you do and it's
like an older guy I'm like oh I make
youtube videos he's just like you know
driving yeah
oh my Disney Channel oh okay like great
you know I mean so it's a it's a
difference of the two and what the
neighbor situation thing did is shed
shed a light on to what I was doing and
everything that I had going on and it
made it so that like basically anything
I do now gets picked up in the press and
like that's why I could the Kardashians
are so successful because of all the
drama and and all that stuff that they
have going on so and you kind of live by
this the classics and like there's no
such thing as bad publicity all press is
good press right and the thing I'm not
sure choking out girls yeah yeah that's
not that you're doing I know
nice terrible but like although it works
for Chris Brown the problem no but the
problem maybe I should have a girl he's
more famous than ever yeah that's bad
okay but like the the problem is is that
the all not all press is good press if
you're like actually that person got it
so the thing is is like I'm not that
crazy guy the neighbors and I people
don't know the real story like so
eventually the light will shine that
like I'm not like this crazy guy jumping
on like KTLA new or their ardent
neighbor is not actually mad
there's only like three neighbors the
ones next to us the ones like across the
street and then like some down the
street when I went to go talk to these
neighbors a lot of them are like oh no
bro we're fans like keep going you're
doing your thing and so it's like the
three neighbors and I can understand
dude like there's fans outside of our
house at all times yeah 3:00 in the
morning 9:00 in the morning I just made
I have a friend who lives near you in
the same neighborhood or near the Tim
ten house and he sent me this picture
just from yesterday and man this was a
long time ago right like this story
broke and look at this picture just from
yesterday and there's like a [ __ ] mob
outside it's not a very wide let's
picture yeah you can see there's like 20
or 30 people like a lion yeah yeah and
and like so it's still it doesn't seem
like it's gotten much better for the
neighbors um we have done our best on
what we can do all we can do is not like
go outside and be like lighting stuff on
fire and doing crazy stuff and being
loud which to be honest is like not even
that big of a problem because none of
that affects them and we're not allowed
at night it's just during the day while
we're making videos or whatever and we
have asked again for our fans not to
come to the house but like we love our
fans and they love us and they're going
to come they know where we look and then
on the other hand you guys like put it
you put your address publicly yeah
because I think what everyone thinks
that yeah
everyone thinks that we put our address
like online for people to come which
isn't the case there's a there's a
YouTube video like a while back like
right when I started vlogging that says
like I found the team's an address and
it shows like clips I'm like how he did
it and like I did a drone shot and he
likes all people are afraid of Rain Man
bill they're just so to clarify how did
it get on uncle Google as a business
address because if you type team 10 your
address shows up and it says this
business and it's even got ours yeah I
don't even know that's something I had
like a bunch of reviews and [ __ ] and I
think I think it's like fans or someone
put it online huh and we added a crazy
thing about it I think that Google
requires some kind of verification
from like the address owner to lista I
mean dude I don't know and but but I
don't know how it got on there but I do
know that a while back before any of the
neighbors stuff even happened when fans
like it was like 1 or 2 fans showing up
we try to get the address off
we're like who put this up let's get it
down let's get it down let's get it down
let's get it down and like I still think
it's up because like knowing that they
like won't let us take it down yeah that
will never go away yeah but now yeah now
it's a thing we're like people just know
our address and literally like type in
team 10 on your account like it'll take
you to route oh my god so kids is
putting on that it doesn't blow your
mind the kids are showing up with their
parents like that shocks me yeah it's
and I the hardest part about it for me
is like I want to take pictures of each
and every one of them but there's so
many people that it would take like
hours of my day every day to say hi or
so and so then so then like and it
started the whole situation sucks for us
too because I leave my house and these
kids like are they're asking to take
pictures I'm like hi hi sorry I can't
take pictures like whatever and then
that but then their parents are like we
drove here you're a jerk you're a jerk
I'm like dude no you can have my house
exactly like I feel like a zoo animal
you know I mean yeah like it's like
welcome to the exhibit like they're
outside our house like filming us and it
it's just a bad well knowing that you
didn't put that address up there I do
feel bad for you I heard this one I
guess you like any ask youtubers or I
mean us and other youtubers who are
usually so careful about showing any
detail that may give you like a hint of
where the house is because we know that
people will find it immediately so I
wonder if you guys were like new to
YouTube and you didn't know that you
should hide it more yeah I mean we gotta
just do it filming in the front yard I
mean it would be easily identifiable but
I guess it's hard to predict that it
would turn into such a circus yeah but
and we're trying to like move in stuff
so it's your tribe but you're still
living there yeah we did eight that's so
great well here's what I want to do I
want to take a short break I want to
come back in a quick five minutes I have
some questions for you I want to talk
about team ten I won't talk about all
that and that stuff going on there cool
and
I'm just going to do a quick thank you
to our sponsors and we'll be back after
that do you want to do you want to go to
the bathroom or get water anything I'm
you can sit here if you want what I want
to eat chips I'll go here I go chill for
like five minutes and then we'll be
ready to go thanks Doug
all right thank you everybody for
hanging out and hanging with us with
Jake Paul coming up later we also have
Chris wolf from KTLA is going to be
sitting down and joining us about all
this team ten fiasco
pretty excited to sit down with all
these guys but so far I'm really
happening Jake you know Dustin give a
quick thank you to our sponsors first we
have a nature box all right now nature
box is a online snack service these guys
make some bog snacks take it from me I'm
a fat monster do you want tips about
food you know you can trust me all right
naturebox has a hundred snacks that
tastes good and actually better for you
they're all made from high-quality
simple agrees which means no artificial
colors flavors or sweeteners so you can
feel good about what you're eating which
is good for me because I usually feel
bad about everything I eat
I say meat they are actually great
snacks did soda and they're healthy for
you armen at least they're not that bad
it's a it's actually a great deal you go
on they've got all these snacks they
update it I'm telling you it's killer my
favorites are the sriracha cashews the
coconut cashews and let's not forget the
jalapeno popcorn spicy hot guys if you
go to nature box.com last lash h3 you
get three free snacks with their first
order that nature box calm
you to nature box for sponsoring us and
next up we have meat undies who makes
the most comfortable underwear and the
whole [ __ ] planet soft and cushy so
when you're done gorging on the on the
nature box
like I do I'll sit and I'll eat 20 of
them they're like this is healthy you
can feel good about it I'm not
not at the quantity that I I guarantee
you'll feel bad if you eat as much of me
but it's so good you're going to want to
so I ate 20 nature boxes and then I'm
like I need some soft flexible underwear
too
don't hold my obese body and then I head
over to me undies okay I got some
yummies here it's so soft it's so cushy
it's got design so you can express
yourself yeah most people I don't show
my underwear to anyone the expression
part doesn't connect with me personally
I like it
you know you likes it it looks like you
know what you're really expressing
yourself today but it is the soft and
it's the most comfortable I'm telling
you you go pick this up your boys are
going to breathe here they wrote this
copy that actually made me giggle what
was it it's a something about the jewels
let's see here
I wanted to read this part the Andes is
the anyway something about the jewels
your junk is your most power you know
valuable jewels are you going to lock
those in a vault you know or that what
they wrote
you know this I'm riffing on I'm riffing
are you going to put those in a vault
under a key are you going to just put
them in your top drawer I put my
valuable jewels and the best place
possible and that's me on DS okay here's
the deal get 20% off your first pair and
free shipping by going to me on DS comm
/h 3 my friends it's a no brainer you
get 20% off your first purchase with
Free Shipping and I'll tell you what
there's a hundred percent to get a
satisfaction guarantee if your boys
ain't click your boys aren't fresh and
flopping or secure but you know whatever
comfortable then you get your frickin
you get a refund I think that yep you
get your money back if you don't like
leave and return it so guys thank you so
much to our sponsors head on over to me
and ease comm /h 3 if you want to cradle
your jewels with the best bank in town
to annotator and market for some snacks
considering it over to March nature box
help support the show by supporting our
sponsors thank you guys so much
all right so here's what we're going to
do I think Chris is here
but I want to do one more segment with
Jake do you want to take a break do you
wanna use the bathroom you just want to
hop right back in um I couldn't do it
away so we're going to take a quick like
two minute max breaker I'm going to go
say hi to Chris Peter little bit right
back don't go so guys don't go anywhere
this is just beginning okay up next it's
going to be weird and wild and by the
way thank you to all the twitch prime
subscribers you guys are the best
be back in two minutes welcome back
everybody to the h3 podcast live with
Jake Paul what up what's going down on
man so we basically left off I wanted to
ask you about team ten I'm fascinated by
the whole thing I've never seen anything
like it on YouTube it's like a youtube
boyband
you guys are like rappers you're like
I've never seen institution like this on
YouTube so I first thing I want to ask
you about it's like the merch is the
merge operation you guys have is bananas
like how much how much volume how many
articles of stuff do you sell like
monthly um for me it's not about like
how much I sell it's like it's like
about like I want each kid to like have
a piece of clothing that that represents
like for my merch specifically is like
getting better every day smiling every
day working harder every day and because
of that thing it's like turned into more
of like a movement and I've talked to
kids in like schools and it's literally
like oh what piece of merch do you have
of Jake's what piece of merch do you
have of Jake's where it's like it's it's
gotten massive and like basically
anytime I meet like a fan they're like
they have merch on and it's crazy that's
powerful to connect on that level yeah I
have a friend of mine who ordered some
of your merch and he had mentioned that
you hand-delivered it that's right
that's really Dutch you do that for
everybody
you know all the only up welcome love
what we what were you thinking like when
you got that order and decided to like
go to his house with it these are mean
yeah I'm just curious
clearly you know this yeah another
source and I was there yeah ah no but I
was so confused I was like okay talk
smack about me on the h3 podcast and
then a couple of days later tweets out
that he ordered my merch so I'm like all
right what's going on here like is he
going to get the March and try and like
burn it and like make a video about it
is he going to get the merch and like
try and wear it in his next music video
and my clown it and I was like I need to
go ask the man himself and it was it was
like a playful thing to me so in your in
your head you felt like it was more
likely he did it for me yeah I thought I
thought he was gonna like mess with me
or like I feel like Yoshi like screw
this kid right with my marchand like
claw me and um I was like I told my
friends like you know like we should go
hand-deliver this like this would be
this movie this would be funny but if if
he gets pissed and there's like no you
can't record this whatever I'm going to
totally respect that and be like we
can't we can't even put this any of this
in the blog and so we were logging the
whole thing with the idea that he was
probably going to be like like screw you
go away and like on our website and
stuff it's like it says like there's a
privacy policy and like all the stuff
and it says like you know we need we
need their address to be able to deliver
it and like that's for the merch quad
you don't fill the you know center right
yeah
but with like any of that like did you
never cross your mind that maybe it was
inappropriate to take his address I mean
in retrospect you think in retrospect
yeah it was respect I totally messed up
like also there's something a little bit
presumptuous about being like I'm in
time like I think you're going to clown
on me and be I'm entitled to confront
you at your home about it that was the
part that kind of rubbed me I think of
all the things you've done that's
probably the thing that I think you
deserve criticism for yeah no I totally
get it do you agree
Aston yeah in hindsight like I messed up
like in hindsight like I should have
reached
like yo can i head and deliver this to
you from our video right um but I'm
always like the one that like just goes
for it and I'm like asks for forgiveness
later or like you think that lyrics are
flower you think that's a good thing
I think it's a good thing the reason why
it's it's a bad thing in certain
situations but in my life in general
it's been the reason why I have success
because it could have been like oh I'm
just going to sit here in Ohio and make
vines or I'm just going to move to Los
Angeles next week and become a movie
star saying you're impulsive not
impulsive but like I'd Emma go get her
well one I don't know that I would
equate those two things but being like a
go-getter
or maybe invading someone's privacy and
also like so I know you filmed the front
of his house like the whole [ __ ]
thing which was a nice which shocked me
as someone who really values my privacy
and then yeah I know and I saw in the
vlog you said did you tell him that
someone was across the street filming
from the car like sniper no but I did
ask my was like y'all are you cool if we
vlog this yeah but that I mean that's
like a far cry right from someone in the
car filming the front of his house I
don't think so really because you're in
you're at his doorstep with a camera
there but I could have but I could have
filmed I could have been vlogging while
I'm walking up to the doorstep
I think it's like common decency to no
no I agree I agree I messed up I'm just
saying like this is what was going
through my head right and when he was
like you can vlog this I was like oh my
god this is going great and he was so
cool he was like he's not he's the
nicest guy ever right and and that was I
think I don't know if it was your video
or someone else's that was like oh well
he was just being nice totally get that
okay but how hard is it for him
afterwards if you like didn't want to be
like no on his own property how hard is
it for him afterwards to hit me with an
email to hit me with a Twitter DM to be
like hey I thought about it I don't what
you did I don't I think the way I said
that when you asked him is it cool if we
vlog this that's when the vlog started
right I think he didn't know that there
was footage before it no I was recorded
I mean I had the granite because the
camera was pointing down you're like can
i vlog and then you like put in his face
and then when you wrote on pants on yeah
you know because it's like oh let me put
on my pants if we're going to film it's
kind of a weird
anyway yet this sniper shot from the car
I don't think that's implied I'm messed
up I messed up I'm sorry post sorry very
lazy so extending it I don't mean to
drill you no no I like any drill because
dude the only way I can get better is by
making mistakes you know and learning
from them uh and there's there's really
no excuse but like I'm just trying to
paint a picture like what was going
through my head right here yeah but then
like the reception too was like you
didn't you never heard from post I
assume right hmm
no but then like you never deleted the
video which I which is what I was
expecting and you put like a little blur
it wasn't really effective it was more
like a like I mean you guys put put that
same blur in your video though so we
blow the whole entire thing you did it
through YouTube yeah and it was like
just like a block no I blurred it in
Premiere I blurred the whole thing we
went back in YouTube and blurred the
whole thing to you can't really do that
on YouTube it's just like a block that
covers the house and then the rest is
visible right pretty much well I know
I'm rambling yeah but ah yeah I mean we
blurred it as much as possible and I
know other people are using like the
footage set like well on the same boat
there with the blurred footage not
really anyway all right let's move on
forget about this are you mad at me I'm
not mad no I'm not mad don't be mad I
just feel like you're not being real
about it in a way because it's different
than what you're saying that what I did
is the same as what you did and that's
patently not WR like you blurred the
footage in a little block but we went
back and we blurred the whole day at the
video editing software on YouTube sucks
you can't really blur it the only way to
effectively remove that footage would be
to remove the video which I can't bro
why is every day bro you know how you
have like superstitions about like leave
it doing a video every day
dude like it's night it's like is my
catchphrase bro like I can well like
simulate yeah and and for
[Applause]
there's no reason you would ever delete
a video no I would but not not for that
not for that because we blurred the
whole thing and it's like and and not
not even that but even even the parts
that we did below that was the only
revealing part of it if you have no idea
where he lives
look out I cut I want it I kind of want
to pull it up but I don't know if it's
worth getting into that deep into it I
don't think all right let's move it on
yeah anyway you know whatever and I
would have YouTube edited like cut out
the whole entire thing but after a
certain amount of views
you can't cut it I know that so yeah it
was either delete or or or shitty blur
yeah shitty blue okay I mean if when you
when you compromise someone's like
privacy I feel like doing that gesture
of erasing it would have been the right
thing to do instead of being like I have
to upload every day and this video is
still getting views so I need to do a
shitty blur and keep it up even though
it might compromise the strangers
privacy who I showed up as house and
never asked me to you know like I feel
like of those two options that's the
right choice and that and what you'd and
like leaving it up with the shitty blur
is like you know yeah the best that's
just my point that's all
again if you would and again if he was
like yo can you delete that but yeah you
never reached out to if he was like if
he was like yo cannot post that you need
elite it I would have done it but the
man himself never did it it's kind of
like the neighbor situation almost right
like everyone was like they used KTLA to
talk to me that's interesting yeah they
never I know close talk to you and and
he sorry about it right but like he
never talked to me yeah it's like if he
was like yo chill he's a video even now
if he if he hit me up now yeah my post
is your open invitation but like no
one's I guarantee I guarantee has gone
to his house guarantee because of that
video you can guarantee it I guess we'll
find out well anyway I don't think it's
a huge problem for him I'll tell you
that it's not the house dice to tell you
that's just no he didn't yeah yeah he
never he never was like he'll make this
video about you know yeah I thought he
did text me right after you came to his
house and he's like Jake Paul just
showed up in my house with the [ __ ]
but he but just just for clarity for you
he wasn't it didn't cause much problems
for him you know and he never did ask
you to erase it so just being fair to
you on that one so anyway let's move on
past that
so tell me team ten as we were getting
into that we took a little bit of a
[ __ ] yeah segue LRAD David like a
[ __ ] path up that tell me about like
your rationale for for like establishing
team ten was that you're the CEO right
yeah yes so basically my my goal was
like all of the social media stuff that
I do is like to innovate and take it to
the next level and do stuff that's never
been done before and I saw this flaw
when I first moved to Los Angeles that
like no social media creators were like
down to help each other they were but
they weren't you know saying like it was
every man for himself and I was like
that's a flaw like everyone on social
media should be helping themselves
helping each other collaborating and
being like a family and everyone will
grow from it but instead it was like oh
I have ten million and you have nine
million
I can't collaborate with you but then
this ten million person would want to be
like I want to collaborate with the 11
million person right as there was a very
flawed system and so I was like all
right I want to create this team and
find like young creators and help them
blow up their careers and then from
there we're just going to continue to do
that and do that and do that it's going
to come I mean it has become the most
powerful team on the internet it's
impressive what you guys are called like
I can't [ __ ] lie about that thank you
so you you created it along with some
investors right yeah exactly I don't
know it much about the investors but
like essentially how did you guys come
how did you meet them how did you come
up like come together because they
invested like a million dollars right
yeah artists yeah yeah so I raised a
million dollars from investors to start
off a company I'm very like
entrepreneurial but I can I can sit down
with anyone and have a conversation I'm
friends with like some of the biggest
business people that there are in like
the space and I basically just started
hustling and finding investors and doing
like the whole startup route right
like starting a company from ground zero
and based I told them I was like yo I'm
going to take these people grow them
like crazy and then from that we're
going to have content we're going to
work with brands we're gonna you know
sell products merchandise we're going to
you know have videos on YouTube blah
blah blah and then it took up a ton of
my time there was like a six months
there where I was starting team ten work
I wasn't making like any content but I
knew that in the long run I was going to
create an empire versus like just being
that I feel like that's come to fruition
now after all the work you put in 100%
because I like the example I use is like
people are like Oh Logan past you and
I'm like no no I I'm the owner of like
over 80 million followers online so he
really didn't and like Logan has to keep
on blogging like I get stopped blogging
right now and I have 17 other people
that are creating content on a
day-to-day basis so on your like brand
or whatever yeah under teen times so you
so you are you partners with investors
basically this was your idea yeah and
you went out to find investors yeah so
what what do you do with the million
bucks would like to start team ten like
what would you do with that money
yeah so it was like hiring employees
because it was becoming to a point where
like I was doing soma right off I needed
like hire lawyers you know start the
whole businesses I've extensive part of
it like pays for the team ten house we
had like five and going on that house
no we rent it okay we rent it yes is
that landlord must hate you right now he
loves us yeah he's like spray paint
people are writing on the walls bro I
don't know he just loves us and like a
trip I don't know it's the weirdest
thing ever
can I ask what's the rent there it's
like 18 thousand a month I guess that's
why I love the um yeah yeah yeah then
get you can [ __ ] transfer please yeah
Prince level yeah it's expensive but a
big house though in an expensive
neighborhood the exactly so but yeah and
then part of part of it is like we're
working on like different tech stuff and
different like products that we want to
launch
and it's only been like a year of seeing
10 so it's kind of image like crazy this
crazy year yeah how's the business work
like what is the model like what's the
business model do you guys take a cut
from everyone who's in like is yeah like
you take like a management fee or
something from people who joined the
team yeah so think of it like a record
label right we call ourselves as a
social media label record label finds a
young artist sometimes there they have
zero followers whatever it is and they
take a percentage of their career in
exchange for you know all this promotion
you know whatever it is like the
benefits working with brands
relationships all the set up you know
there's a lot that that the talent
benefits from you market them to he's a
long yeah that's the biggest one I think
mm-hmm I want I like my goal is like oh
it's like I want to be like dr. Dre like
he had this big audience that he used
and he would sign like younger artists
and teach them how to make music brand
and market them to his audience outcomes
mmm 50 cent Snoop Dogg interest to talk
and then he uses that collective to
launch beats by dre so it's almost like
I'm doing the same thing but in social
media so when you're how many people are
in team 10 right now you're just like 15
so so the 10 is completely the 10 rows
per tent there's 10 digits in a billion
dollars I will get this straight billion
all right there you go so I'm ambitious
but how close are you probably rebellion
yeah ah not close a billions a whole
other League but people get there yeah
and like it's it's it's hard to get to a
billion but over time like I know we're
gonna get there one day
like nothing is that your gold and you
want to be a billionaire one of my goals
yeah I have a lot of goals I want to be
the really ones I want to be the world's
youngest billionaire yeah love who is
the current yeah want to carry on beagle
of snapchat how old is he
26 oh my god you have much time dude six
years I mean six years look at the
feelings a lot of money died yeah no but
you know this startling how do you act
realistically get to a billion dollars
from where you are
I mean you need some crazy [ __ ] now so
how do you get there do you have a
business plan yeah what you guys know
100% brave shark just based off of like
team ten alone and like merchandising
and and the relationships that that I
have and implement and like investing
money into like different startups and
real estate and the different tech
things that we're working on and nothing
is impossible
oh [ __ ] wait why are you at ten mill
yeah I forgot to check it oh okay we
still have some time okay glad we're
getting there you're definitely gonna
hit it while you're here that's pretty
special
let's lit I'm not gonna let you leave
until I am and you share that yeah I
want to hijack that moment from you
alright um no but but I'm always I'm all
for like I mean look what's happened in
just the past year like everything I've
done done in the past year has 10x you
know it's like what can happen next year
and the year after that and so if I get
I get better and better and I'm doubling
or quadrupling what I'm doing every
single year yeah in six years who knows
where it could be
when you hit a Billy dude just hit me up
man I'll [ __ ] mow your lawn or some
[ __ ] I'll clean your pool or whatever
you need man alright my gosh I'm not
flat I'm not planning on this much
longer for me that's negative okay I'm
kidding but seriously though just hit me
up all right I mean it's your bro what
are you looking for when people join
team ten like is how many people are you
always accepting applicants you have 15
ah it's let you limit it yeah I think
it's limited I think the biggest thing
is when you find someone great you bring
them in yeah more so that and it's like
and it's like we're family like there
any more there any time where you're
like man I everyone [ __ ] hates for
this guy that was a huge mistake I mean
those are the people who aren't in it
anymore oh right yeah you guys kick
people out how many people have you
kicked out ah
to [ __ ] those guys right I'm not saying
yeah yeah they can yeah they can do
whatever they want
obviously like I mean I won't even get
into yeah that's where I'll even have a
relative what they call you irrelevant
no no nothing I just
okay everybody leave here but no well
whoever they are they probably didn't
choke out a girl so it's T oh [ __ ] what
I didn't know we're talking about it so
let me see you you live in the team
townhouse full-time yeah yeah you don't
have a second house were you like I
don't want everybody waiting for me in
my house
you have the master bedroom right yeah
it just filled with merch I do know why
cuz do we have so much Martians we just
put the racks in and then everyone takes
it everyday and just where is it let me
shoot at people and throw it out to fans
oh you're actually you're not selling
the merchandise you just like suck it
exactly we look anything goes like
sometimes sometimes I'll just take like
a trunk full of merch and just hand out
to fans that like randomly into the
streets that merge situation has bananas
who sells more merch you or your brother
cuz I know I know Logan has an insane
merge operation - yeah it's um I I know
I do well you have a whole I guess you
have a lot more people right selling it
well just just me and Logan individual I
know I do but it's it's like some days
it's back and forth but overall and I've
been selling it like a month or two
longer than him so overall I know I've
sold more and we talked about it
sometimes but we're basically only like
heads a head like every single day
whoo it's crazy it's going to be
interesting have your brother as your
like biggest competitor do you consider
him a competitor I can I mean as far as
like YouTube is concerned like I don't
mean like this to sound cocky yeah like
he's like my only competitor it's like
it's like one - and who's through three
you know what I mean
what is it about him that makes him your
competitor you mean like fast growing
vlogger or you mean PewDiePie everybody
nobody's on your level I would just say
like innovating the game not not even
the numbers wise like right but
creating content on a day-to-day basis
because that's the new that's a new way
of YouTube you have to do everyday bro
yeah exactly obviously and on it so
people who create content every single
day that narrows it down to a small
bucket driven people in there who are
going viral like more than five million
views a day there's there's really no
there's not that many um and so that
that's what I mean and I think I think
another thing on top of that too is like
I think it's gotten to a point where it
like has become mainstream like what
we're doing because there's a fad like
how fast you've grown um and so it's
just like a whole nother level like moms
will come up to me and like dads will be
like my kid watches you every single day
I bought him the merch I bought like
they know of me because of that do you
think it's sustainable the household is
i I've been mean Gila try doing daily
videos for like a month like a couple
years ago and it was the worst month of
like our lives where I was miserable
yeah and everyone I know who does daily
videos hates it
yeah and I know you're juggling sewing
things I want you're making daily visits
sustainable like how do you feel
actually about it 100% sustainable
really for how long do you see yourself
doing everyday videos
I think it's until I there's a reason
business-wise
that I can meaning if I like get a big
movie role and if you can't film on set
so that's the only thing that would stop
me but you so if you've got a big movie
role you would still daily vlog just not
when you're on set and then maybe you
have to skip a day though you're saying
or you stop completely no I would still
try to I try to I would put I wouldn't
try to do anything I would do like what
is good content for people to watch like
if I could film a vlog still in a day
while I was on set shooting a movie and
it's a good piece of content that I'm
happy with and I'm going to put it out
but it's not good then I'm not I'm not
going to put it out I got to but
something but if the movie set would let
me film on set then it'd be easy like I
did it on Disney literally people don't
realize that like I was there 8:00 a.m.
and left at 5:00 p.m. every day like for
the majority of my holder like past 300
something days of vlogging
and so I'd get home at 5:00 and be like
let's go like turn it on so we have lamb
yeah
oh sorry good no it's almost to a point
where it's like I want more because like
I I don't know I just like you want to
make more yeah [ __ ] go to video today
markiplier doesn't yeah but those are
gaming videos so it's like game and then
post mmm does that make sense yeah yeah
it's like I mean yeah you just got so
anyway Chris just walked in from KTLA
have you spoken to him since the
incident no not at all cool it's gonna
be a good yeah so chris is here we're
going to take another short break to say
what up to Chris and get all situated
hang back for another short two minutes
and we are coming back with two legends
that we're going to dab on the halos and
yeah stick around guys we'll be back in
two minutes
welcome back everybody to the H Street
podcast here with Jake Paul II local
owners and our new guests who just sat
down with us Chris wolf of ktla who they
wrote the original story with Jake was
gracious enough to join us today and
have a little I say intervention but
that's a joke it's not right or wrong
it's more of a rendezvous but you have
you had something first that you wanted
to uh yes share with us yes there are a
lot of requests the boss audience yeah
they're great
you know it was enlightening is what to
mean you know that I yeah I wasn't on
that I was ruined around oh you did okay
I do it first okay but you know I had a
blanket but a lot of the story with the
cameraman on my shoe saying I don't
think you like my shoes I'm not you
edited it perfectly I was that dramatic
hand to your face I guess you didn't
like my shoes so good well thanks for
joining us here today thanks for having
me essentially you know we're here to
talk about the neighbor situation with
teams and that surrounded that initial
reporting you made
the neighbors aren't here but I guess
you're familiar with a lot of them you
know about the situation there so you
kind of representing them a little bit
in this conversation so I suppose my
first question is like how did you you
know get involved in this story
interestingly it's not like people
called me up and said you got to put
this on TV oh my god a lot of times
that's that's what we get you've got to
do this story you got to cover the story
you got to put it on TV and we don't
take anything lightly we we consider
every story very carefully it's usually
consensus with our bosses but and
coworkers
and and it's sitting around a table and
discussing sitting around a table and
discussing the whole issue I was
originally approached by will just say
someone close to the story a person or
persons in the neighborhood they simply
wanted me to be a moderator at the
meeting between the neighbors and the
city officials okay so hold on let me
stop you right there so there was a city
town hall meeting dedicated about the
team ten chaos did you know that yeah we
did we tried to attend it my god were
you going to blog it no no we're just
wanting to see like what people were
doing what what was going on we want to
be involved in drama too so that we
could help fix the situation right but I
don't we couldn't find out like the info
on it is Jake okay so and so you
migrated they even kept a lot of it
secret for me too because once I did the
story no I did not moderate what
happened was while I was interested and
the reason is journalists are always
used as moderators for debate in
residential today well I guess yeah I
guess I didn't know the presidential
debates debates town hall meetings they
typically used journalists as moderators
so that's why they approached me I knew
of my work and I was approached to do
that while I was interested I said now
explain to me though the reason for this
meeting this forum and they told me
about the situation in the neighborhood
and I said well this sounds like a news
story I think it's a valid news story
and I would like to cover it and talk to
all the parties involved you the
neighbors anyone that wants to talk to
me I want to hear what you have to say
and I felt it was a good story so a few
days later I pitched it to my
supervisors at KTLA and they agreed they
said it's a really good story go get
your photographer get your news van go
out to the neighborhood we did
that Monday in mid-july I had no idea
what to expect I really did I was not
too familiar with you but interestingly
when I looked you up I remembered that
you had been on the morning show yeah
and turns out you had been on our
morning show in June 2016 about a year
earlier promoting something so I
remember that I was like you know and
and in all fairness and I said that in
my story I said we've had Jake on as a
guest on our morning show and I don't
know what you were promoting maybe
YouTube or Disney Buzard bark or
something yeah I think I was I think is
new at that yeah and so you know I went
there I went to the neighborhood I did
approach a lot of the neighbors they did
say they were very upset of the
situation but the vast majority did not
want to go on camera maybe they were
concerned about repercussions or
retaliation how many how many neighbors
did you speak to because how many
neighbors do you have immediately a lot
okay yeah I basically I was going
door-to-door I was feeling hey I was
walking to a lot of the neighbors came
out because they saw the news van there
they would just come out and I would say
hey we're doing a story do you want to
talk they would tell me how they felt
but they would say we're not going on
camera yeah
which makes sense right so most of the
people or all the people you talked to
had a problem with the teen town yes we
go one honestly no one said oh we don't
have it because I would have used that
if one neighborhood read we really the
kids get Jake is getting a bad rap I
don't think he's a bad neighbor I would
have used that too I'm there to collect
everything I prayed because when I is
when I talk to them I went door to door
as well yeah and like for three or four
of them or like no like I hate you then
let I would go and talk to you I started
off my conversations by Mosin hey we're
here we want to make things better and
like that's our start a conversation and
a lot of them were like no do like
you're fine like it's all good I'm not
that mad like yeah this has happened it
has happen but like well I understand
where you're coming from so so you see
that's the whole thing that yeah I want
I've just pulling that up for you well
everybody's doing it me money where they
unsub when you're about to hit it
they're doing a Mima on me well yeah
like when you're about to hit a big
milestone people unsubscribe just to
[ __ ] with you nice people and Jen
because it keeps going up and down oh
you'll get there hopefully career and
noggin is really interesting so you talk
to all your neighbors and fifty percent
said I have no problem with you and then
that's that's weird while the I wonder
if they just didn't want to confront you
about it yeah maybe I mean maybe they're
just like get out the way from me but
yeah and I think the thing is that a lot
of them like are saying that they have a
problem with me when the problem is the
fans outside that was causing all the
problems the safety the traffic so noise
for chanting right there [ __ ] because
they believe you though for bringing
that exhibitor because I think because
of those things they think I put the
address on there they think that I
invite them there when I act an
actuality I've tweeted don't come a vlog
don't come there was that one incident
where you like recorded them and accuse
someone of like taking the bolts out but
let's touch on that later because I want
you i want to continue where you left
dr. so a lot of them did not want to go
on camera they just said we really are
upset with him in the situation here and
the whole you know team 10 house but we
don't want to go on camera so they did
even I believe right next door to you
Jake there's an elderly couple they I
knocked on their door they had like the
outer wrought iron door open with the
well closed but then the main door open
and I could see them sitting in their
living room and I knocked I said hello
I'm crystal from channel 5 I'd like to
talk to you and they said no thank you
we really don't want to talk but thank
you and politely declined and that was
pretty much what I got and one man did
go on camera but did not want his name
or face release well we just i used a
short clip from him his voice when he
said we're neighbors and were fed up
that was one clip that i use from him
and then i made tall the woman in the
air it was the only neighbor
yes i'm sorry to tell you all not really
there jake was asking to grab his camera
nation right about local Nathan which is
kind of a big mind big so I'm YouTube I
need my diamond I can never
deny that request as a youtuber myself I
don't know you're going to hit 10
million is that it just all luxurious
networks have gone up and down like
thousands in this brief moment well when
it does I guess you can just close the
door and hang until it so anyway you can
I think I think we're going to be here
all day so I think it damn may call the
only one that would go on camera
the who was in the initial story that
said I feel like it's a war zone we're
families we just want a peaceful quiet
street right she was the only one I
could find that was willing to go on
camera so of course okay I use that so
did it suppress it it's kind of I think
Jake fugly about hit it oh there oh that
looks good it's gonna go so it's gonna
jump back down I want of law with it are
you good don't you clean Excel oh my
gosh
oh so convenient they have a giant
monitor to celebrate oh thank you guys
yeah thank you so much I got a solid
right over there yeah well good
congratulations man thank you all right
we can find is written in the course
take take the one similar to as I've
said love or hate you or think you're
okay yeah appreciate the hustle you
earned that 10 million for sure
thank you Congrats dude graduate that so
YouTube where's my plaque yeah I need it
you'll get it in a year they think it's
a joke
in frost because you going back under no
oh no you're kinda like it now okay good
yes okay yeah you're good thank you dude
so anyway oh my god did I'm gonna move
all right no no no don't go back
everything is oh it's that bigger okay I
can't see it we can go in the room where
we will revisit at then see where yeah
so were you surprised when when Chris
rolled up with his van and with this
whole story about how the neighbors are
all upset and you would talk to them
before after Chris before I was a
conversation with them for a while come
on just like just like face to face
stuff though like they would like and it
was always them like saying something to
me or like coming over and knocking on
the door and being like yo you can't do
this
err or so that's how you knew that there
was some beef to be go because they were
coming over and telling you to keep it
down yeah exactly
never call the police all the time okay
yeah that was like their go-to thing so
were you surprised when when Chris
rolled up in his van well I I didn't
know we didn't know what you want to
talk about right I think I think the
only thing you said to someone was
they want to talk to you what the
neighbors yeah and so someone came into
the house and was like yo Jake KTLA's
outside they want to talk to you about
the neighbors and so I was like oh this
would be fun you know what's interesting
at first the female security guard who
is out front she went in and she came
back out she said they're not going to
talk that's what I heard and I said okay
well then we tried right and honestly
that's what I thought
so we went back toward the front of the
house with the fans and within five
minutes that's when you ran out and I
was like okay I guess he is going to
tell her we go here we got to go there
we go
what were you thinking when you saw Jake
climb over the band like a maniac were
you like this is some good footage yeah
oh yeah I mean I was surprised and you
know we don't recommend that and
shouldn't it's dangerous you had a lot
of equipment up there and you're going
to put it around your neck climb climb
well I you know what maybe want you
wanted me to climb no yeah and no good
TV you like don't do in your mind I know
but you know I don't I don't yet know
and believe me there have been
situations where a lot of the protests
in the streets that we've covered in
downtown LA near City Hall where people
jump on the vampers start not the first
time and that is a frightening situation
but oh yeah I mean that that is
definitely scary and are they're trying
to vandalize the vans smash the vans or
put graffiti on the vans that's that's a
very very dangerous situation but you
know you were up there I thought you
were just doing you know it's
interesting some people said we can't
believe he was disrespecting your job
like that and I said I don't think
honestly I said I don't think he's
disrespecting my job as much as he's
doing his own which is to you know be
sort of outrageous and whatever they
jump up on a news van and well that's
I've said early to come down and you did
you got down yeah well that's I said
earlier like if someone doesn't know me
they're like this kid is the worst but
like anyone who like it was a
Treiber they're like this is the
funniest thing I've ever seen like only
he would do this so did you guys expect
the cover the coverage of this story was
insane never I have a list like in DES
and locally it was covered everywhere
but an international you've got the
Daily Mail he went well New York Times
Vanity Fair cosmopolitan and I mean I
saw like Seth Rogen tweeting about it
did you see that [ __ ] yeah he's not
happy with you Seth Rogen was going in
hard yeah I mean I mean the biggest
thing like people were hitting out there
like bro Seth Rogen just tweeted about
you right
I like dude what are you gonna do and I
don't know like dude are you worried and
I was like dude who made Seth Rogen Seth
Rogen who made the rock the rock who
made Kevin Hart Kevin Hart like no one
makes anyone so I think his tweet was
like I'm not gonna have any part in
helping him become a movie star I was
like dude you have no say over that
right
ah like you made yourself I'm making
myself like yeah if you're a producer on
a movie you could be like screw this kid
but like he's not going to be like that
like I mean he's going to see the you
don't see the light in like Who I am
further down the line I'm gonna have to
prove it to anyone like I'll have a
battle now against like blue hey Jay
Paul but obviously was like I mean it
was like a stunt and like that's who I
really am well what was your oppression
after you came out and you finished you
were done filming and you're in the van
going back to the station or whatever
what were you thinking after you got
that footage to do have any expectation
like damn this is cool oh I knew yeah I
know it was TV gold I mean I knew it was
a great story and and I was glad that I
got all the parties and I could talk to
Jake and say look this is what the
neighbors are saying what is your
response and I got his answers to my
questions and I got the neighbors
reaction so I felt there was a solid
complete story when I knew it was TV
gold but I never expect I don't think
anyone expected it to go viral boys and
within a couple hours I think we were on
the front page of The Daily Mail and in
London in Europe and then the next
morning someone said oh my god Chris
they pulled it up on their desktop and
there it is front page of The Daily Mail
that's when I knew I was like oh this is
this is going viral
uh what do you think about Jake
afterwards because he was putting on an
act and a stunt like he was what are
those look what do you think about Jake
and you left I didn't think and I don't
think you're a bad person
I really don't never did I mean I've
dealt with the best of society I've
dealt with the worst of society
convicted killers on death row in
Florida on stark Florida so I know what
evil and bad is so I never thought that
that you you were that I just thought
you I guess I felt that the situation in
the neighborhood is very difficult and
and you know a lot of the neighbors
simply feel that their sanctuary their
home their homes have been violated with
this presence and these fans and there's
noise and everything else and and I just
and I person as a journalist but as a
person first and foremost I I wish the
best for everyone you know I think
you're you're a brilliant entrepreneur
and you're brilliant of branding and
like selling yourself and more power to
you for that and this is the land of the
American dream and you're following and
building yours and all of us hopefully
are yeah and same um but I think there's
got to be a good resolution and I would
hope that everyone can live peacefully
the neighbors get their unity back and
peaceful and you can do what you want to
do and you seem to be of the state of
mind of like well we tell our neighbors
not to come that's we're in the house
are sorry we tell our fans not to come
we're respectful in our house and our
property what can what can we do right
did I summarize your yeah and I think
the answer to it and not I've like met
with the neighbor one neighbor who's
like you know teen up like their whole
meetings and stuff like that and we
talked about it like for a good 45
minutes and the only solution to it is
for us to move that's really it fans are
gonna listen when I tell them not to
come right they're going to come here
the cats out of the bag so exactly
Jake Paul is the strongest family out
there set on the interview I'll say it
again Deb he's gonna see I'm saying that
so it's like they're going to come
they're going to come so dabbing
like a solution - no it's not
unfortunately sadly some things can't be
resolved by doing yeah so you guys are
actively looking to move though well
we've tried to move even before you guys
came yeah I can imagine people to want
to let you move into their house that's
a problem we're dealing feel like who
are you like you're the guy in the news
yeah it's nothing like an alias even
before that we have to we had to go
through an alias like someone else's
name that like isn't affiliated with us
but like it's still going to live there
they can be pretty go in there like wait
who's living in my house I don't think
so because in our new house like you
mentioned earlier like we're not going
to show our address we're not yeah yeah
oh yeah we're going to be so careful and
buttoned up like we learned our lesson
so yeah and I want to apologize too like
if I was being disrespectful at all like
I didn't mean to - like dis your shoes
but it was like in the human gut saying
it's okay my shoes have a bigger fan
base now yeah we're cool of your Twitter
though it's good don't know what's it no
my good really we're beating into it -
Yama savage yeah you were excellent I
was active on it yeah and and and some
of it may be to my detriment I mean I
got some blowback some even some
co-workers I think really although they
didn't say to my face I heard that they
were not happy what we outlined with how
I how involved I was and felt I was
being unprofessional right maybe to a
degree I was but I know I wanted to be
engaged and it was in terms of reach and
impact probably the biggest story of my
career which I never expected and I was
ill just I mean I don't know it was a
good bad we've got the most viewers
we've ever had by far we have 68
thousand people watching right now which
is by flight Emoto there's some [ __ ]
weird thing do you just pull in the
number of numbers like it's undeniable
when I sum puts Jake Paul in the [ __ ]
video they get double of you know how do
you explore do you think about that I
think it's great I think it's also a
problem because it's like it because
they're like situations like this like
if I do one thing bad everything because
because well and again I'm not a cocky
person but like we my brother and I we
are at the top and
people want to see us fail who want to
join us down if you want to make stuff
up about us and they want to shine the
bad light on us because at the bottom
line and it's crazy like people don't
like to see other people succeed like
unless they're genuinely good people but
I feel like the majority of even like
the internet and like people out there
just like they don't want to see other
people succeed does it feel good though
in a way where you're like I can always
pull the numbers even when people are
hating on me it's yeah I mean it's cool
it's cool right just relevant it's yeah
it's relevancy but to me I don't want
the numbers to be there for the wrong
reason I think sometimes they are
because a lot of them are are people who
hate on me which sucks because like I
don't want anyone to hate me does it get
to you the other amount of hate you get
no no not at all because I like I said
hey all publicity is good publicity I
think we were talking about it earlier
like because of that news story and like
how viral it's got and now like anything
I do will get depressed from good to bad
so I think it's helped me cross that
bridge in the traditional more and it
there are some things on like damn that
sucks that people are saying this and
like I don't want you know people to
think of me this way and that's sort of
what I care about but I don't care about
like what people say necessarily if that
makes sense why is it deep that you
think that people have this like
aversion to like they that people have
this general like they want to hate you
so badly I think it was a snowball
effect kind of you think it started with
vs. reporter I guess I was it's everyday
right yeah that was the first you can I
do it what do you think about that it's
interesting right is that so what would
most hates right or dislikes what was
the one like the seventh most disliked
video I mean that's accomplished it is
and and what I say is like a look at
this number two is Justin Bieber I'll be
Justin Bieber every day of the week I'm
not saying I am or as as talented as him
but like if we're you know it's someone
like him when he was younger
took all that hatred and turned it in
the biggest he's the biggest star I mean
people respect Justin Bieber now exactly
it's much like oh [ __ ] that kid lucky
you but he used to write and yeah he was
involved in some issues with the
neighbors remember well yeah yeah oh
yeah we covered usually ground number
Lilly he I heard the neighbors were
saying he was racing his sports car I
don't know if you had a re or what he
was racing a sports car in the
neighborhood they were saying you can't
do this we have small children running
around and I heard he got into a fight
with one of it I think a next door
neighbor and it was really nasty and it
got physical and lucky there were issues
in the reason well that's and that's
what I've liked honestly I feel like
I've learned so much and I have such a
different respect for like just
entertainment in general and like I've
tried to grow from this situation which
I think was what Justin did is like I
can only learn from these dumb things
and like I said it's a snowball effect
it was like it's every day bro than the
news thing and then you know like the
post Malone thing and it was all this
stuff that added up where people like
kept on getting strong and Jonah turned
into a meme kind of just to like hate on
Jake ball it is a thing Italy is a thing
it's like if I tweet something like I
got a puppy and I tweeted about it and
someone like quote tweet saying goes
like I'm so sorry for you puppy and I'm
like does that bother you no I'm just
like dude like you you are you that
starving for content right nowadays like
get a better tweet like right like you
don't need to drag other people down to
build your tower higher does it bother
you that everybody on YouTube is making
Jake Paul videos and still are kind of
because it's like that's all like Louie
I think keemstar was like past 20 videos
a definition in the title is basically
[ __ ] star
yes he's basically at Jake Paul 3 at
this point yeah yeah which like that's
what he says he talks about what's
relevant right yeah so anyway he's just
it's the nature what I don't like is how
they're using me to get their videos on
there like more viewed and then they
like try to drag you down it's like and
a lot of times they're not telling the
truth about like my side
historian and only only like the people
actually evolved will ever know what
actually happens and there's a lot of
like fake news and stuff out there and
like yeah let's let's talk about the
lawsuit I know that there was I don't
know if it's real I don't know if it's a
rumor but everybody's heard that the
neighbors are mounting a lawsuit against
Jake and I'm sure you're you're involved
in that right welcome well they've been
telling us yeah and they've been saying
right now from what I'm hearing you are
you know pulling back you're trying to
make an effort to make the situation
more livable and peaceful in the
neighborhood so they're holding back on
the lawsuit but that yeah so what we're
not ready to to take any action right
now because they are seeing a change and
hope they want to continue to see you
know improvements I think they would
like you to take from what I'm hearing a
bigger stand to tell the fans although
again we don't know how successful that
may be yeah but they'd like for you to
take a bigger stand to say to the fans
do not come here you know to try to
discourage them from coming it's
actually been better because school just
started did this video I don't mean to
like I said this because from our this
pictures from yesterday dude look at
this holy cow they're right across the
street I mean all they're not all in the
street yeah yeah and God knows what's on
this side wait didn't you paint over
that graffiti on your garage door or no
well yesterday yeah I mean yes your the
day before okay
like in preparation for this for this
conversation okay this is very so like
is how can you take a more strong stand
against your fans who are populating
outside your house
it's a tricky it's a tricky thing
because it's like I love my fans so much
they are who that they're the reason why
I'm at we're on that and like they're so
loyal to me and a lot of the ones that
come to the house are like the most
loyal ones
and so I've in a nice we're told not to
come but I can't be like in their face
about it because I don't want them to
ever feel like but surely there's a
polite way to be like guys I appreciate
you coming but you're getting me in
trouble like in a vlog or put a sign out
and be like please like every shade that
you want to come show me love but you
can't come so it's crazy because my
brother got evicted from his apartment
because people were going to the parking
garage across the street and chanting
his name across there across the street
and he made a video he's like dude I'm
about to get evicted they warned me they
warned me I'm about to get evicted
please do not come I'm begging you like
I love you guys he made this video and
still done that Gator show up and start
chanting his name whatever it is yeah
like I couldn't you could you have
guards outside he says don't everybody
go away yeah we have a full-time
security but it clearly it's not very
effective well we can't tell them to get
off the sidewalk Rob what what is it
what are the neighbors think Jake should
be doing that's a good question um what
do you think can be done I mean I don't
know I honestly my feeling is it's
probably too late with the fan issue
because the address is out there and it
just it's too late I really don't see
any effective resolution to that if you
tell people please don't come they're
still going to come I like I said I
talked to a neighbor about it even much
like the loss to stuff and like the only
thing we can do is move I know so we're
working on trying to go fair enough yeah
what was the lawsuit for by the way
public nuisance public in this public
nuisance and I don't know all the
details of what major public news an
estranged on that is what they were
saying it's a public nuisance lawsuit
take it from me you don't want to be
sued oh yeah you guys have been sued
yeah for copyright infringement but it's
been going on at a year and a half oh
it's been a nightmare dude tears have to
go to court and stuff we already we
already talked about our depositions and
stuff but we don't have a court date but
we're just waiting for the judges it's a
nightmare dude so just get avoid that
[ __ ] and I'm sure the neighbors don't
want to be involved yeah there are lots
right nobody yeah
it was so expensive
definitely and it's time-consuming and
it's uncomfortable so you know I think
they're saying if we feel like we have
no other recourse we're going to do this
but I don't think anyone really one you
have to take it a level good I know
life's too short
negativity yeah so is there anything
that neighbors want to say to Jake or to
the world or something that you guys
want to say I mean again I'm you know
I'm not what I hope you understand I'm
not you know you're not either I'm a
messenger you know I'm not here with the
neighbors going
Oh Jake get out you know I am I'm a
messenger you know I'm a journalist now
I document things and I bring all sides
to the table and that's what I really
try to do always each and every day and
and I think the neighbors are saying
they're just they still they're not sure
what the ultimate solution will be yeah
probably like you said just been
relocating and and maybe being in an
area remote enough that you can do what
you want to do your stunts or even greet
fans on your property if that's what you
choose to do so long as it doesn't
impact the neighbors your neighbor in
yeah okay do you think that's just
curing about your nose yeah I think
that's the only solution is moving far
away and not showing our address and an
undo a property that's big enough
swegen yeah you need a property with
walls exactly yeah like a whole wall
yeah yes
so all right good luck with that
expensive I saw a blog you were looking
at like our new place like teaser were
you really considering that place
because it was like that would look like
a fifty million dollar plus house oh no
that was out a quickly okay good yeah
guys lose weight right leg right you
know yeah you didn't break click bait
and the I guess not you're right not
click Yeah right that is whenever I put
you to sleep a it's not closely for
night but about me too open-ended
okay and sometimes it's not click me and
I don't put knowledge weekly so you just
watch everything every day just do it
through that through all right well I
have a question for Jake we're going to
see your career going I mean what do you
want to do in 10 years yeah it's a good
question I see myself being like 50%
social media and 50% traditional so I
want to be well I am writing movies I
wrote a movie acting in TV shows movies
auditioning and building up that side of
myself as well on the social side
continuing to create my own original
content and growing that and pushing
products to that and pushing my own kind
of businesses through that and like yeah
like I mean I am an entrepreneur I have
team 10 I invest we're working on a
couple of tech things and so I see like
the celebrity side of me growing all of
those businesses and it kind of being
this like ecosystem of things that that
feed off of each other as goals to be a
billionaire yeah want to be real
speaking about earlier wondering 10 to
10 is potatoes computer so they'll take
care of all of us when we're there
yeah you won't forgive or more of those
shoes grow well I I really appreciate
you coming we had some laughs and gaffes
got a little serious had some moments
but we was developed we worked it out
feels great yeah it was good and I you
know I think it's tough I think it's
cool I think it shows a lot of character
that you came here and confronted all
this stuff so thank you I want to
acknowledge that appreciate that and
congratulations on 10 million has
Congrats the girls really thank you so
much Chris Wolfe thank you leg showing
but cut again thanks to you about this
it was my pleasure really
I'm thrilled to be a part of this yeah
I'm very happy good discussion how was a
now I know I'm wrapping it up but like
how has this been for your career this
whole story it brought me to a new level
with social media really I mean that I
had not seen before it was unexpected
and unbelievable people from your world
generally don't have not engaged mouths
no he didn't know we were trying to but
this really just took it over the top my
deals
got you all right party Lana all right I
think we got something hold on your
pants no good are you auditioning
because this story brought me to your
audience in social media and all of you
and it brought you to my audience and
more mainstream traditional media right
and it really was like a crossover that
you guys collabed essentially yeah and
there was a net positive is what he's
trying to say yeah yeah cool yeah it's
been really interesting awesome yeah
well I think you both I think you're
both very great people I think really
coming out here thank you Mike was so uh
thank you guys thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed that yeah just really
appreciate all you guys and both you
guys and stay tuned we'll be back on
Tuesday for our top of the week we're
starting to do podcast on Tuesday now's
when you're doing it twice a week you
can find it here on YouTube as a treat
podcast channel thank you guys take you
to a sponsors big they would subscribe
will switch bride that's it see you guys
next time goodbye